[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
an
fajiialal
nous sommes au sud de la Jordanie à 350
km de la capitale am dans un fascinant
et hosle désert de GR
rose en pronon ce nom ne sait pas qu'il
désigne en fait Laurence d'Arabi
guerrier romantique habile stratège fou
illuminé en cet endroit le jeune
lieutenant Laurence avait réuni les
armées arabes pour vaincre l'ennemi turc
la légende est partie d'ici et raisonne
encore dans le cœur des massifes
[Musique]
environnant
far est un petit bédouin et le wirou v
solitude minérale sculpté par le vent et
la terre des bédouins leur nom bad en
arabe signifie précisément habitant du
désert possédant de très fortes
traditions les Bédouins ont su malgré un
développement certain conserver leur
culture ils sont organisés selon une
structure patriarcale au sein de
laquelle la cellule fondamentale est la
famille
ض
يرخل فيه وان
فيré la dispar préur du pèreette
différente des autres les rôles sont
répartis entre hommes et femmes et toute
l'éducation est conditionnée autour de
ce principe farad étant le seul garçon
tradition oblige sa mère tente de plus
en plus de lui faire assumer le rôle du
père
disparu les tâches entre hommes et
femmes sont très distinctes c'est à
l'homme qu'il revient de s'occuper du
troupeau principale source de revenu de
la famille pourtant dans cette tente
l'organisation sociale est quelque peu
modifiée d'abord parce que farad était
trop jeune lors du décès de son père et
qu'ensuite il suit une scolarité
normale tous les matins à l'exception du
vendredi jour sacré chez les musulmans
farad accompagné de ses deux sœurs Katma
et Aziza se rentent à l'école c'est
farad qui a lâ charge de conduire le 44
qui les achemine pour parcourir les 5 km
qui les séparent du village de Rome
c'est grâce à ces petits détails que le
jeune garçon montre qu'il prend très à
cœur les responsabilités qui lui sont
progressivement confié par sa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mère
au même instant dans le campement Hamda
la sœur aînée prépare les provisions
nécessaires à sa longue journée de
[Musique]
pâturage les Bédoins sont des bergers
nomades et toute leur vie est organisé
autour du troupeau cette famille ne
déroge pas à la tradition et cette jeune
adolescente emmène chaque matin ptre ses
bêtes dans un endroit plus
propice
an
[Musique]
Hamda et son troupeau ont atteint le
puit aens halte nécessaire pour que les
bêtes se désaltèrent l'eau est rare dans
le désert ne boiront à nouveau que ce
soir après le
[Musique]
retour
ayant changé de vêtement transition
entre le milieu nomade et le monde
moderne les enfants peuvent maintenant
se rendre en
classeat ETA respectivement gé de 14 et
11 ans rejoignent leur école dans le r
la mixit pas les jeunes filles vont dans
une école publique alors que les garçons
comme farad sont scolarisés dans un
établissement géré par des
militaires dans cet endroit reculé de la
Jordanie l'armée prend en charge la
scolarisation des garçons il est
nécessaire d'astreindre ces enfants
nomades à suivre des cours normaux
nomadisme et école ne faisant pas
toujours bon ménage les militaires
donnent des contreparties comme la
distribution de couverture et surtout la
gratuité des fournitures scolaires ces
quelques avantages incite l'enfant mais
surtout sa famille à doger à certaines
obligations
[Applaudissements]
traditionnellesrere Corre
[Musique]
la première partie de la matinée est
consacré à l'anglais deè langue parlée
en Jordanie après l'arabe dans cet
endroit l'expression linguistique fait
partie d'un ensemble qui se veut être
aussi un facteur de changement ces
enfants sont les vecteurs de cette
évolution modernisme les valeurs
traditionnelles s'effacent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
progressivement
pendant ce temps Hamda conduit son
troupeau de 40 têtes vers des pâturages
plus riches elle emporte avec elle une
petite flute fidèle compagne et signe de
ralliment du troupeau depuis toujours
les collines et les dunes sont le public
discret des douces mélodies interprétées
par ces petits
bergers
an
hamda7
واaj
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
FAJ
[Musique]
empty
spaces what are we living for abandoned
places I guess we know
[Musique]
this does anybody know what we are
looking
for another
Hero another
mind
[Musique]
autre sacrifi de la scolarité Henda
s'active tous les jours à des tâches qui
s'avèrent parfois être très lourdes pour
une enfant si jeune
انا
اسفي
nouveau contraste entre la vie nomade et
le monde moderne ce cours de biologie
terme de cette journée d'école comme la
majorité des enseignants qui exercent
ici le professeur est un civil et dépend
de l'éducation
[Musique]
بدويه والطابع القبلي البدوي موجود فيها
لانه المنطقه كلها عائله حده مترابطه مع
بعضها البعض طلابنا نتيجه الامتحانات اللي
انا كنت اعملها
للطلاب لاحظت كثيرا ان الطالب يعتمد ما
اشرحه جاوب على اساس اللي انا بشرحه بالصف
قليلا مايقرا في البيت نتيجهانشغاله معواح
والسياحه في المنطقه المحيطه فينا لذلك
فهو مستوى الذكا عنده عالي جدا
واحناسعى بصفه احنا تعليم وتربيهه نرفع
مستواهم الاكاديمي لكن بعض
الطلاب احيانا ما بحبوا يكملوا دراستهم
فبجوا
لسياحه واحنا موجودين هون من اجل خدمه وت
وتص لمرح عل من الده الجامعيه والدكتراذن
الله pour les tribus bédouines les
dromade constiue le bien le plus
précieux il représente une source de
revenu importantees produits particulier
le lait constitue encore aujourd'hui la
base de l'alimentation des familles
c'est aussi pour eux le moyen de
transport le plus économique et le plus
fiable dans le Wadi room tout le monde
est équipé de chameau y compris le
desert Patrol le corps béoin de la
police du désert veillant sur la
sécurité des habitants ces policiers ont
aussi la charge de patrouiller sur les
frontières l'Arabie Saoudite n'est qu'à
[Musique]
km
merhab ya FAJ
h
le tourisme autre facteur du modernisme
permet à ces jeunes enfants grâce à
quelques de gag beaucoup
d'argent
[Musique]
le prix d'une promenade est de 20 dinars
190 Fran français somme importante
surtout pour des enfants de l'âge de
Farage le salaire mensuel jordanien est
d'environ 250 dinars l'équivalent
seulement de 12
[Musique]
promenades
tous les chameaux du monde ne suffisent
pas à s'acheter un ami dit un proverbe
bédouin malgré la considération que ces
nomades affichent pour leur
monture ces gens du désert ont pour
habitude d'aller droit au but et ne
respecte seulement que quelques
principes et conventions la nature sil
la pensée même leur approche de la
religion est différente des sédentaires
aucune expression de groupe aucune
manifestation tout se joue dans
l'intimité de l'être Dieu est nature et
la pensée est prière fort de ces
principe ils ont su conserver de
nombreuses traditions notamment le
partage de la nourriture symbole
d'hospitalité et en premier lieu le pain
fabriqué à chaque repas il est constitué
d'une pâte fine ce pain simple
accompagne
lait légumes et les féculant qui aliment
les repas
famiaux par tradition toutes les jeunes
filles de la famille doivent aider la
mer le préparer
entre deux cuissons et autres
préparation il n'est pas rare que les
sœurs de Far l'accompagnent dans
quelques moment de détente je de Ball et
parfois Mar les
agrément
[Musique]
le repas du soir est symbole de
communion il se déroule généralement
dans un silence religieux et chacun y va
de sa main droite piochant généreusement
dans le plat commun
pas de chichi chez les Bédouins on aime
la vie comme on déguste un
plat puis vient la veiller autre lieu
autreur ici pas de télévision on profite
de ces soirées pour réviser les cours de
la journée tout le monde participe les
enfants scolarisés partag le connaissan
nouvell avecamda et qui n'ont
malheureusement pas la chance d'aller à
l'école
nouvelle journée mais le rit est
identique chacun assume les tâches qui
lui sont imparties dans ce cycle
particulier une activité a son
importance le tissage considéré comme un
art majeur il fit par le passé la
renommée des femmes bédouines dans la
tente voisine de la famille de farad une
femme confectionne avec une grande
dextérité un tapis les tentes sont aussi
fabriquées à partir du tissage mais en
poil de
chèvre le poil de chèvre particularit
d'abord il se rétracte en cas de pluie
ce qui permet d'imperméabiliser la tente
ensuite la chaleur écarte ses fibres et
crée ainsi un système d'aération
naturel un peu plus loin à proximité de
son campement far sonore d'une tâche qui
normalement devra être réservé à
l'ADUL
entièrement dépaissé par les hommes
l'animal sera accommodé et cuisiné par
les femmes selon une recette
bédouine
an Amri 13
يء
[Musique]
18انء
غقتححب
[Musique]
مبشتوقت
ياراي
[Musique]
والم الغفل
قبلكقبل يا يح وين مسافرروح تعيا
وتولي شحال ندمبا
[Musique]
الغفلين
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de valeurs sont associé au
partage de la nourriture c'est pour
cette raison qu'il règne au sein de la
tente de farad toute cette effervescence
jour de fête oblige ce soir on dégustera
le monsf ce plat traditionnel bédouin
constitué d'un riz épicé se mange avec
de la viande arrosée d'une sauce
yogourt l'expression artistique pour les
Bédouins revê un rôle très important on
se retrouve parfois le soir au coin du
feu au du rythme lancinant de
l'instrument de musique traditionnel le
rababa il est composé d'une petite
caisse de résonance avec un manche et
plusieurs cordes tendues on en joue à
l'aide d'un archet fait de boyau
d'animaux les air sont répétitifs et
l'arrive parfois que le rythme d'une
chanson fasse écho au son du rababa les
paroles des chants traditionnels
bédouins expriment l'amour la poésie
mais il parlent aussi d'aventures
légendaires de guerrier de la vie et du
destin de puissantes tribu
dans cet univers sublime et titanesque
le plus intrigant est peut-être la façon
dont l'homme natif de ces lieux a appris
à
s'insérer quant aux enfants le wirum
forge leur vie pour far et ses sœurs le
contraste entre modernisme et tradition
est de plus en plus présent et il
suscite parfois quelques nobles
ambitions
[Musique]